at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can I ask a question
[Music]
medieval scholar hello boys and girls
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to a
very bucolic episode I'm sitting outside
with the birds and the bees the flowers
and the trees of the Tim Ferriss show
where it is my job to interview
world-class performers or world-class
experts people who are in the top of
their fields and this episode is a panel
the panel relates to psychedelic science
and it was recorded at the 2019 Milken
Institute global conference and this
particular panel was standing room only
there were several hundred seats all
filled and then the entire room was
surrounded by people standing which was
really surprising and also encouraging
to me because this is a conference
comprised of primarily investors many of
the best investors and certainly most
lauded and objectively in many respects
successful CEOs in the world very very
unusual to see that type of crowd in
that room and a few notes before we jump
into it it was a fantastic experience a
lot more to share another time on that
we have a number of different types of
participants in the panel we have
incredible scientists we have investors
and we also have writers who have
experimented with micro dosing and there
are a few visuals that are referenced in
the beginning a number of slides that
are presented you don't really need the
slides to understand what is being said
and I'm a nerd for the science you will
be able to find those slides and links
to the studies at tim dot blog forward
slash podcast with all of the other
links to everything mentioned in this
episode so if
goto teamed up blog forward slash
podcast and search psychedelic you will
certainly be able to find this episode
and find all of the visual references
but you do not need them to get the gist
of what is being said in the first say
nine and a half minutes if you want to
skip directly to a first-person
description of micro dosing and what
that is like or what it can be like I
should say and certainly not
recommending that you do anything that
breaks the law wherever you happen to be
color within the lines would be my
recommendation but if you are curious
nonetheless for informational purposes
what such an experience is like that
comes up around nine minutes and thirty
seconds in and without further ado
because I do make make because I do make
for [ __ ] sake I do make much ado about
my introductions please enjoy this very
wide-ranging and detailed conversation
about psychedelics and psychedelic
science thanks for coming everyone I'll
keep my introductory remarks pretty
short but I'd like to begin with a show
of hands how many people here know
someone who is depressed despite the
fact that they take antidepressants
anyone all right
how many people have anyone in their
lives affected by addiction alcohol
opiate or otherwise all right so the
entire audience for both questions lest
we start on a complete downer let me
give an inspirational story and it
relates to catherine mccormack a name
not many people know I'd recommend that
everyone look her up on Wikipedia she
was born in 1875 in Michigan she was
educated at MIT as an undergrad where
she lobbied the administration to change
a requirement that women were hats with
feathers because they were a fire hazard
in labs she said very true so they
changed that she also inherited a good
portion of the International Harvester
fortune
and in 1953 she met a man named Gregory
Pincus who was developing an oral
contraceptive he had lost his funding
because his backers didn't see any
profit in sight and over the subsequent
years pretty much single-handedly
financed that development and in 1957
the FDA approved the pill for menstrual
disorders so that was sort of the
strategic first indication and then
later we know what happened and the
reason I bring this up is that in total
she provided two million dollars in
funding in today's dollars around 23
million over many years and it was an
uncrowded bet through which she was able
to completely bend the arc of history
and I will give some disclosures now so
in 2015 I stopped all my early-stage
tech investing and redirected almost my
entire focus to psychedelic science for
reasons that I think will become clear
in this conversation and have been very
involved with both Hopkins and Imperial
which has been incredibly gratifying so
with that let me introduce our panelists
we have Christian and Goethe Meyer
founder of a pyrin investment group we
have Robin Carhartt Harris head of
psychedelic research center of
psychedelic research department of brain
sciences material College London Matthew
Johnson associate professor department
of psychiatry and behavioral sciences
John's Johns Hopkins University School
of Medicine and I elet Waldman author of
a really good day subtitle how micro
dosing made a mega difference in my mood
my marriage and my life so let's begin
Matt with some of your slides if we can
bring those up and I'll let you take it
from here sure slide 3 so really
important before we get into the meat of
some other conversation is to let you
know that we've been ahead as a field in
terms of understanding being very clear
about the risks there are downsides so
you ask any Jedi Knight about the force
they're gonna tell you in addition to
knowing the good side you need to be
aware of the dark side and how to keep
it at bay same thing with psychedelics
the so-called bad trip is real there are
other risks as well but we published a
paper over a decade ago that has now
essentially become the
of how to conduct these studies it's
been used by institutional review boards
at a growing number of universities and
I was at the FDA last week they are
using these guidelines to evaluate novel
protocols recently published another
paper assessing the abuse liability and
risks of psilocybin and thoroughly
reviewing the scientific literature and
suggesting that if psilocybin which is
the active agent and so-called magic
mushrooms if it's approved ultimately
through phase three trials as a medicine
that it belongs in schedule four based
on the data rather than scheduled once
or we're aware of the risks were paving
the way we've analyzed the data in terms
of some of the now we've got the the
dark side out of the way what's the
light side we can look at some of the
efficacy data very quickly so next slide
number four please we published the
largest couple years ago the largest
study examining psilocybin in the
treatment of depression and anxiety
associated with a serious
life-threatening cancer diagnosis these
are people that are freaked out because
they're gonna die and this is
essentially like the addiction work it
is picking up on older threads of
research largely done with LSD back in
the 60s you can I'll tell you briefly
about our results here on the right
looking out at depression results on the
left and then anxiety results in the
right panel the leftmost points on those
figures under baseline that's those are
the high levels that people had when
they came into the into the trial and
trust me this is a clinically severe
level of depression and anxiety post one
the next time point on both panels the
red group has received a high dose of
psilocybin this is not a microdose this
is a very large overwhelming dose
something you don't want to be at a
concert on you see a huge reduction into
the non-clinical realm I mean these
people are
not having problems at those lower
levels around 8 on the scale you do see
a good reduction in the people in the
blue group and that's a group that to
this point has essentially received a
placebo it actually is a very small dose
that you could call Micro dose in this
trial really just designed to serve as
the comparison condition essentially a
placebo so that's probably due to the
very careful preparation that were poor
building and also some of the so-called
placebo effect at the next time point
post - that's a month after they've
everyone has received the high dose so
the people who had gotten the trivial
dose in the first round they have now
also received a high dose now they have
dramatically decreased their depression
and anxiety just like the group that got
it a couple months before and then the
really mind-blowing thing on the last
point in both panels is at 6 months
you see sustained reductions in
depression and anxiety six months after
treatment from a single high dose
session and so in terms of depression
there's understandably a lot of
excitement around ketamine which has
recently approved for the treatment of
depression in that it has immediate if
an try depressant effects that last one
to three weeks which is wonderful get
ready because we might be at an even
higher plateau when it comes to
sustained effects with psilocybin so
I'll jump to the the next slide
these along the addiction angle we
decided to do something novel that
wasn't done in the 60s one of the
interesting things is it appears that
this isn't just specific to one drug or
another like methadone for opioids or
nicotine replacement for smoking but the
anti addiction effects of psychedelics
seem to be broad-based they get to the
psychological meet of addiction so why
wouldn't it work for tobacco smoking
people have tried to quit smoking we ran
a small open label pilot we had
dramatically impressive results at six
months we found that a
percent of participants were
biologically confirmed as smoke free
breath samples urine samples
you know we trust people but we verify
those results held up to to 67% at a
year and 60% at an average of two and a
half years after there's after their
target quit date and in this study they
had three psilocybin sessions most
participants just to tell you how
impressive these results are the best
medications we have such as varenicline
which is chantix gets up into the range
at six months at about 35% nicotine
replacement anywhere depending on the
city between 10% and 25%
it was an open label study so we have to
be cautious the the real question is is
visits warrant follow-up and the answer
to that is apps are free can loot lis
and so we're in the middle of that
randomized trial at this point so this
is just a taste of a number of trials
that have gone on in the field that are
telling the same story that the earlier
era of research from the 50s through the
70 showed that there is huge potential
of these psychedelics and treating a
number of psychiatric disorders thank
you that I own let's jump to you because
I'd like to contrast or maybe not
contrast but add to the scientific
discussion the personal discussion and
your experience can you talk to how you
ended up micro dosing what micro dosing
is and what effect it had that's a very
big question that I'll I'll let you so
micro dosing is the practice of taking a
sub perceptual dose of a psychedelic
drug I mean you can make it us anything
but in this case we're talking about
psychedelics so when I say sub
perceptual I mean you do not trip you do
not have a hallucinatory experience you
see no kaleidoscopic colors the idea is
to take a drug dose that you cannot
perceive of any effects but that there
is something going on metabolically so I
was experiencing serious depression and
I had not I had been on
accessorize I had been on mood
stabilizers I had been on various
medications and they weren't working
effectively and so I decided to try
micro dosing I had been a professor at
UC Berkeley's Law School and taught a
seminar called the legal and social
implications of the war on drugs during
the course of which I read the
psilocybin research I read the research
that you know from the very from the
1930s on through the present day
research and I was I you know made sure
that what I was doing was safe I made
sure that the drugs that I was taking
were pure that is the most important
issue when drugs are illegal you have no
guarantee that what you get when you buy
from the illegal market is actually what
you think you're getting and I embarked
on a 30-day experiment micro dosing with
LSD so what I did was I took a 1/10 of a
dose if you want to say have a
hallucinatory experience at Burning Man
you're gonna take somewhere between a
hundred and two hundred micrograms LSD
is a very potent drug so we're not
talking milligrams we're talking
micrograms I took ten micrograms and I
took it every three days and the effect
was profound so the first day I had been
in a suicidal intractable and hedonic
depression for what seemed like forever
because when you're depressed you have
very little capacity to remember when
you weren't depressed and the first day
I took the drug I swallowed it early in
the morning because LSD is activating
and I didn't want it to interfere with
my sleep and nothing happens so I
thought all right well this was a bust
and I got to work and about after about
40 minutes or so I looked out my window
and my dogwood tree was in bloom and I
had this thought oh look the dogwood is
in bloom it's so beautiful now it wasn't
like the petals were bursting into color
and taking off butterflies in the sky
but I had been unable to appreciate
Beauty for months and I saw it and I
understood it was beautiful and it made
me feel happy and that was an experience
that was really mind-boggling
over the course of the next period that
I was taking LSD micro doses it wasn't
like every day was a really good day but
many days were really good days and my
setpoint of depression dramatically
changed my productivity I wasn't in it
for mind enhancement for productivity
enhancement when my productivity changed
dramatically the book that you can buy
afterwards at the bookstore was the
first draft that was written in a month
now I've done that before in periods of
hypomania but I had never done that in a
period of productive calm flow so I
became convinced at the end of this
experiment that this was a drug that had
all the therapeutic benefits that are
promised by SSRIs but I often say that
if those antidepressant commercials
showed a fat person lying in bed not
having sex there would be a more
accurate assessment of their effects
than a happy lady skipping through a
field of flowers and I was a happy lady
skipping through a field of flowers
[Laughter]
images messing up my Segway thank you
the microgram milligram difference is
very important so please take close note
of that Robin let's jump to you next
because I really want to get your
perspective on plausible mechanisms
plausible explanations for how these
compounds do what they do because it's
not as though at least in the way
they're currently administered in most
cases they're sitting in your system
saturating your system for say six
months after the cessation of smoking
could you talk to based on our current
understanding based on your current
research what is happening and maybe you
could also touch on the the entropic
brain sure okay so the first thing to
say is that these compounds are working
on the serotonin system an important
brain chemical that modulates a range of
different
important psychological functions we
know mood especially but also cognition
and states of consciousness and it's a
particular aspect to the serotonin
system that psychedelics work on it
particular receptor subtype it's called
the serotonin 2a receptor and we know
from a broad range of different
evidences that this receptor is involved
in you could summarize it as
adaptability flexibility plasticity
there are a lot of these receptors in
the cortex an aspect of a brain that
humans have so much of and so
stimulating these 2a receptors appears
to at a higher level have an interesting
effect on the regularity and the quality
of brain activity so we can characterize
conscious States in a way not analogous
to two waves when we record brain
activity it's very rhythmic and as our
conscious states change that rhythmicity
changes as we fall asleep or if we're
knocked out with an anesthetic or we
suffer some kind of brain injury you'll
see that brain activity starts to look
like sort of slow rollers on a on a
notion and related to that the the
richness of conscious experience drops
away it's very predictable very steady
there's not much going on we know if we
look at normal waking consciousness that
the waves look very different you know
they're much more rap here there's much
more richness going on what we've
discovered with psychedelics is that
that richness is enhanced further and
that was quite an interesting and novel
discovery to our knowledge there hasn't
been a state of consciousness found that
shows that increase in the richness or
complexity of brain activity above the
level of normal waking consciousness
that's a very mechanistic take on things
another way to to look at this and
that's a way of characterizing the acute
experience
not thing to emphasize tying this in
with a therapeutic work is that the
quality of the experience that people
have under psychedelics appears to
predict very reliably the therapeutic
outcomes and so you know these really
amazing findings that the drug is well
washed out of the body and yet people
months on from these isolated
experiences reporting improvements in
psychological well-being drops in
depression and suchlike so what's going
on there and so just quite briefly to
talk about the therapeutic mechanisms
and perhaps slightly frame it in a in a
slightly more sort of human and
psychological way we can think of a
range of different expressions of mental
suffering as being underpinned by biases
and beliefs whether it's in depression
with negative cognitive biases we think
we are worthless and life is pointless
or it's eating disorders where we think
we're ugly or overweight or obsessive
compulsive disorder with those stampton
habits and so that there is this kind of
commonality this trans diagnostic
commonality that that that seems to
relate to a very range of broad range of
different psychological disorders and
what psychedelics seem to do acutely
during the experience itself as they
seek to relax beliefs and open a window
for change for revision and if that
opportunity is seized with the right
kind of psychological support then you
can work towards cultivating the healthy
revision of these pathological beliefs
and habits thank you and it's worth
noting also for people who aren't
familiar that if we're talk about the
psilocybin which in the case of studies
is synthesized it's been used in the
form of selasa tea mushrooms by for
instance indigenous populations
including the mas tex in mexico for
thousands of years
one could argue very very effectively so
there there's a good question we're not
going to dive into it right now but as
to why almost every civilization
excepting a few in Antarctica have used
psychedelic compounds and certainly for
rites of passage but also with an
objective along the lines of these
enduring effects that you talk about
Christian let's talk about investment in
this space and and why you're involved I
know that you based on our conversations
certainly a very sincere interest in
making these compounds more widely
available to people who are suffering
and your biotech company atai life
sciences is currently one of the largest
investors globally aiming to bring some
of these psychedelics including
psilocybin back into the legal realm
what prompt did that and how are you
thinking about approaching it okay let's
start
because you're many investors I'm a
super coward until five years ago I'm
not exaggerating I have never drank
alcohol in my whole life and I come from
Bavaria in Germany where this is like
cultural actually appropriate to do so
but I didn't because I was super I was a
weird kid so I I was super worried that
my brain cells could die and so I didn't
drink alcohol I've never smoked a
cigarette I've never smoked a joint I've
never done anything else till I run
about six years ago some very very
trusted friends tried to convince me of
magic mushrooms and I was like you're
clearly insane yeah I'm never ever gonna
do that till but then I they told me a
lot about it actually what what Matt and
Robin said and and I do invest a lot in
biotech actually biotech is how I
started my career I founded a biotech
companies I was very inclined to read
all the data and the data is very
compelling so ultimately you later I
gave in it was to say that as well it
was a jurisdiction where it's legal and
it was under a very guided and very well
set up protected session was a great
guide and it was the single most
meaningful thing I've ever done and
experienced in my whole life forced oh
yeah nothing comes close to it and which
is by the way in a lot of studies
think it's a John Hopkins study where I
think it was 2/3 of the people ranking
among them five most meaningful events
in their life among persons a child's
death of a parent and I think one third
round about ranks it among the single
most meaningful thing so because I'm an
entrepreneur I came out of the trip the
first thing I did I called my parents
because yeah I realized how much I loved
them and I never say it and the second
thing is was like this should be
experienced by more people and I do
think that the only way to do it when we
have a lot of wave a lot of anecdotal
experience like myself and like I yell
at and we have a lot of it's called
basic research but unfortunately never
these drugs these various drugs have
been brought to the FDA or in Europe is
called EMA sort of life cycle or sort of
cycle how to approve any normal of a
drug you want to use for for medical
purposes so I was like okay this should
be done is anybody doing that and so I'm
embarked on the trip in in a
figuratively world and I've met great
people like George who founded compass
who had the similar thoughts that this
should become a medical drug mainly for
the treating of a treating depression
and then other mental health issues this
is where we our compass is in phase to
be and also back the company which is
bringing our ketamine hopefully on the
market which is a sort of subform of
ketamine also for the treatment of
depression and we're looking on other
psychedelics or wider mental health
drugs because I think if you look at the
numbers and again investors are very
numbers driven the whole mental health
area I'm not just talking about
psychedelics but as well it's completely
more or less neglected but been
neglected over the last thirty years
because it was sort of come the mind is
a complicated thing and I pharma
companies biotech companies thought okay
let's focus on cancer let's focus on the
more tangible
and also to be fair depression our view
on depression and and mental health has
changed over the last decades like 50
years ago what we now call a depression
people would have said go on with your
life go to the gym train a little bit
get well yeah when when people came back
from the Second World War and were
showing symptoms what we now would call
post-traumatic stresses or that people
said hey get on yeah so I think the few
on mental Health's has changed over the
last 20 years but also I think we live
in a world where mental health is
becoming a problem because our world
where we live in is very bad for our
minds especially for young people if you
look at Instagram whatever yeah that
whole sort of way we live and we have
started living the last 10 20 years I
think it's very very bad for the state
of our mind yeah and this is why the
numbers rise we have 320 million people
suffering from depression and these are
just the official numbers and most
probably the the how you say the gray
number is much higher
it became if you count sort of the side
effects like people not showing up at
work and stuff like that it became the
single most costly illness in the
Western world and for like 23 years
there has been no innovation and all the
drugs which are on the market are not
curing but numbing it yeah and again
let's go back to something personal like
if if if a person gets very depressed
because somebody loved one dies you
don't want to take Prozac and Prozac
tells you you don't care about the death
you want to sort of dissolve it and
solve it in a in a different way and I
think this is where psychedelics have a
very promising path to be a very
valuable drug thank you and we're not
going to probably talk about a very
specifically today but the efficacy of
MDMA for post-traumatic stress disorder
is worth looking into and is really
remarkable both MDMA and psilocybin now
have breakthrough therapy designation by
the FDA which is remarkable and if you
look at the
look at the data for changes in PTSD
severity from severe or extreme symptoms
to asymptomatic they look very similar
to the smoking cessation graphs it's
it's incredible Maps as an organization
doing great work there the team can I
add a point to that is the it's somewhat
ironic that I'm the resident drug user
because like you Christian I don't do
drugs other than these I don't smoke I
don't like to smoke weed sometimes I
take CBD cuz you know you can't get a
matcha without it nowadays but I don't
like to experience any Helou like my
mind to be sharp at all times but
because I was teaching the one of the
first sort of people who popularized
MDMA Sasha Shulgin a chemist in Berkeley
used to lecture to my class and Sasha
and his wife and who is a therapist
convinced me to try MDMA which is
ecstasy with my husband as a tool of
marital therapy and we've done it every
couple of years since we have the
strongest marriage of anyone I know
we're sort of famous among our friends
for having an incredibly strong solid
marriage and I do actually we have four
kids we have a lot of stress but the
what MDMA does and why it's relevant I
think to PTSD is it's somehow and these
guys can probably talk more accurately
to it it disconnects the emotional
experience from the memory which allows
you to deal with the trauma of memory
without the intense overwhelming emotion
negative emotional content so in the
context of something that isn't PTSD
buts rather like the you know mundane
PTSD of a long marriage it allows you to
talk about your issues but from a place
of connection and love so every couple
of years we spend six hours talking
about everything that has come up for us
from a place of absolute love and
commitment and that sustains that one
experience will sustain for as long as
two years it's really remarkable thank
you yeah it's
not to delve too much into any current
use wouldn't want to implicate anyone
but MDMA is worth taking a very close
look at there are risks association LSD
yep so there are some risks associate
with these compounds these are not
panaceas they are very effective or
appear to be for certain conditions MDMA
has certain say cardiac risk in some
patients for instance since it is what
is it methyl die oxy methamphetamine
there is that I'm a beginning the
chemical name wrong but then you have
risks with say certain other promising
psychedelics ibogaine for a potentially
opiate addiction which I want to ask you
about not specific died began you have
in the case of ketamine some addictive
potential which I've certainly seen and
even experienced Psychonauts so you have
to be careful with how its administered
but the I won't talk too much about this
but the toxicity profile of many of the
classic psychedelics like psilocybin is
is remarkably appealing so would you
mind that just speaking to the the
toxicity or potential toxicity of say
psilocybin and also what could you could
you speak to based on what you've seen
with tobacco and other forms of
addiction if you think there might be
applications to say opiate or opioid
addiction sure so for toxicity we can
start at the physiological level this is
true for psilocybin LSD
dimethyltryptamine or DMT which is in
ayahuasca there is no known lethal
overdose no dose at which there is any
observable organ damage
not even a potential mechanism for
neurotoxicity that's pretty freakish
cannabis is similar you'd be
hard-pressed to find anything sold over
the counter at CVS Walgreens that you
could say this about you can't say it
about caffeine aspirin most drugs you
can't just take ten times an effective
dose and expect to live or to be and
so remarkably freakishly robustly safe
at the physiological level I would never
say any drug is safe period it demand it
depends on what area of risk you're
talking about so these are very and at
sufficient doses profoundly conscious
altering drugs very intoxicating if you
will when you see harms they fall into a
couple of categories one that's
applicable to anybody that takes a high
enough dose is what people out there
call the bad trip in clinical research
we refer to these as clinical
experiences as challenging I'm sorry
challenging experiences because in fact
they can be very helpful themselves
going through extremely difficult
experiences nonetheless we try to
minimize them but out there in the wild
so to speak recreational use or what
have you and it's certainly a small
minority but sometimes a overwhelming
anxious state can lead to dangerous
behavior someone panics they run into
traffic you know it was overplayed in
the propaganda the late 60s but falling
from Heights it has happened they're
very intoxicating drugs far more people
have fallen from Heights when they're
drunk but nonetheless it has it happens
so in terms of public health this ranks
lowest amongst all the other major legal
and illegal drugs but nonetheless there
is a risk there so nice thing is you can
squarely address that in clinical
research and potential clinical use
through preparation and monitoring it's
never it's not take two and call me in
the morning
follow-up care the other major area of
risk with these classic psychedelics is
only applicable to a small percent one
or two percent of the population who
have active psychotic disorders such as
schizophrenia or a strong signal for
that predisposition and many of the kind
of urban legends we may be aware of a
folks that took too much of a trip and
they never came back it seems very
convincing that those folks had a
predisposition at least such as you
might be familiar with
said Barrett the original singer of the
Pink Floyd and in the earlier era of
clinical research with LSD with
thousands and thousands of participants
the the only people that had prolonged
psychiatric reactions beyond the time
course of the drug were those
individuals with that psychotic
predisposition it's also very fortunate
like the bad trip side that we can
squarely address this in clinical
research and eventual clinical use
they're extremely reliable psychiatric
structured screenings that can identify
peep that small percentage of the
population that has this risk and then
it does modestly raise blood pressure so
we can't run people through the research
who are at an extremely high level of
cardiac risk I mean these are the same
folks that might have a cardiac event if
they go up several flights of stairs
nonetheless that's a real thing and also
in the area of risk we've documented
some systemic effects and increasing the
chances of a headache
within the day following use typically
not in a severe category nothing that we
would think would prevent people from
using it clinically there's a very rare
thing called hallucinogen persisting
perceptual disorder extremely rare it
tends to be well it's all the data show
that it is exclusively associated with
recreational use where there's typically
multiple drugs including alcohol used
and there may be a predisposition there
it's never been observed in any of the
thousands of participants in the older
studies of the current studies so and
what I'm referring to are you've heard
of the term flashback and that can mean
many things but that what this refers to
is having persisting perceptual
abnormalities that severely happen the
quality of life
they're very distressing for individuals
and it it seems to be that that's it's
probably related to a neurological
susceptibility where other events not
only psychedelic drugs but other
medications other events could probably
cause the same
the same thing but he might have heard
that that sort of rounds out the entire
sphere of of riffin own risks thank you
and what about applications to say
opiate opioid right and just if I could
I'll add just a quick personal note so
my cousin by marriage he had a
hereditary disposition to schizophrenia
and really abused LSD all throughout
high school college and it would seem
that it expedited the onset of symptoms
of schizophrenia although very likely
that he was headed there already it just
hastened the path so I've seen that
firsthand
and now on the flip side I've also seen
incredible abuse on a personal level
that is representative of I suppose a
sort of pandemic level problem in opioid
abuse so my best friend
Long Island died of fentanyl overdose my
aunt died of percocet plus alcohol not
too long ago so this is something that's
touched a lot of lives in this room are
there any potential applications you
think or research worth doing it would
look at psychedelics and something like
opiate or opioid absolutely it's a very
promising area there is one study
published in the early 70s using LSD
with heroin addicted individuals there
was you know we needed to do follow-up
but that was right at the point in
society where the rug was pulled out
from this research and the research
wasn't allowed anymore but nonetheless
there was a good initial signal of
long-term success and that's part of
this formula what I was describing
earlier this picture of broad
applicability to treat addiction of
various types my colleague Peter
Hendricks at University of Alabama
Birmingham is is showing initial
positive results in treating cocaine
addiction
so opioids is an extremely promising
area it's something that we want to look
at it's an extremely promising area
particularly in the midst of what's
called the opioid crisis and especially
since opioid addiction is resistant to
treatment
you know we'd have medication assisted
treatment now
that are more effective at keeping
people off so resolving opioid Christ
problems but without medication assisted
treatment opioids you know this
traditional treatments that we think of
like Narcotics Anonymous
they are grossly ineffective so our
current opioid crisis will not resolve
without wholesale accessibility of
medication assisted treatment and I
believe Without Really evaluating the
potential of psychedelic drugs which is
why I actually hope that this crisis
might enhance our receptivity to D
taking psychedelics down from Schedule
one which means that there are the most
criminal drugs there is no a scheduled
drug mean a schedule 1 drug means
there's no medical use and it's the most
illegal drug down to schedule for so
what kind of what other drugs do you
think of that we could analogize that
are on schedule for Oh
many of the benzodiazepine rights and
the sleeping aids are in schedule four
let me let me jump to Robin
for a second because I think that we can
we can talk about perhaps the broad
applicability and perhaps some current
diagnostic problems that we may have in
psychiatry because if you look in the
DSM and we can talk to all sorts of
people who have previously been sort of
at the head of mental health Tom Insel
and others where you have these
disorders these psychiatric disorders so
called disorders that are very cleanly
separate you have anorexia nervosa
anorexia has the highest mortality rate
of any psychiatric disorder then you
have OCD then you have this then you
have that they're all very much silent
could you speak to the explain what the
default mode network is if that's
possible let's just speak to that
because the part of what is fascinating
to me personally is that if we kind of
zoom out to 30,000 feet as you mentioned
earlier you have this kind of high P of
conditions associated with hyper
rigidity and then you have conditions
over here OCD anorexia etc these kind of
compulsive behavioral or thought
patterns and then I have other side II
of this hyper fluidity which can be
problematic like schizophrenia right but
can you speak to maybe explain for folks
if possible the the current thinking
around the default mode Network sure
yeah I mean it's get some free new rule
say it does have that kind of chaotic
component to it but it also has the
rigidity to it as well if you think of
fixed delusions and so this is a
remarkable thing that gets kind of
glossed over in psychiatry that these
diagnostic categories while they're
they're really to aid the clinician
that's one of you another view is that
they're aiding something else perhaps
drug discovery and and such like an
perhaps to some extent a myth that there
are these crisp distinctions that have
crisp underlying biomarkers that
following the the classical biomedical
model we can come in with a magic bullet
and solve solve the situation and and if
that was true then we wouldn't be seeing
the the mental health crisis that we're
seeing at the moment prescription rates
of psychiatric medications are going up
at record levels yet we're not chipping
into the problems so you know we do need
some kind of major paradigm shifting
events here a kind of Black Swan event
that that really changes things and you
know I think our collective view is that
psychedelics psychedelic therapy is is
that it's this hybrid model that's not
just a drug treatment it's more holistic
than that it's about managing context
giving a drug that produces this
suppleness of mind and then managing
context to try and move people out of
the kind of you know entrenched ways of
thinking and and behaving into something
broader and more open so default mode
network is in a sense you could say it's
the most it's the strongest candidate
that we
have in the brain for what you might
call the biological substrate of the
self or the ego it's a system that
engages when we disengage so to speak
well we disengage from attentive focus
but we enter a kind of daydreaming you
know
internal imaginative state but this is
very much tied in with with self and and
the narratives that we build about who
we are that we start to believe in the
kind of absolute way that guides and
drives our behavior but can be so
narrowing you know ego sees narrow and
short and what you see under
psychedelics is that this network breaks
down it literally albeit temporarily
disintegrates and people see broad and
they see the bigger picture analogous to
the so called overview effect you know
that astronauts are described when they
are up in space they look look back at
the whole of the earth and then they can
put things in perspective and think you
know why was I squabbling with my wife
or my work colleague and you know it's
about seeing that that bigger picture so
here you know we've got this opportunity
through brain imaging to start to put a
bit of meat on the bone you know to help
you know lift the lid on this black box
that's the brain and start to show
people that this isn't magic it might
feel like magic psychedelic therapy but
it rests very firmly on nature on
biology and I think it's useful to to
add that to the conversation and help
kind of ground the conversation about
about psychedelic therapy yeah one point
because both I yell a dent and Robin
just touched something important where
disagree with I yell at and agree with
Robin that no secular that it's not true
for all of them but are a very holistic
treatments so partly the setting and the
guide and how every experience is
equally important so why this is my
opinion especially for example on magic
mushrooms that yes they should
be available as a medical treatment but
not over-the-counter this is nothing
somebody should do alone especially when
you're depressed and by the way we all I
think one risk is that most people very
passionately like all of us talking
about Daleks we're not depressed and
it's a different experience when why
when you read observations of treatments
of depressed people they might go to
call it catharsis or to to a challenging
they might have a challenging trip
nevertheless the trip is healing them
and and the guide is very important so
this is why I just want to add that yeah
I personally think yes it should be
available as a medical practice what
we're working on but it should be
available on the professional care like
with psychiatrists or in clinics but not
over-the-counter
definitely not over-the-counter I know I
agree with you entirely you know my book
I have a whole sort of chapter about
paradigms for decriminalization and you
know my ideal paradigm for psychedelic
decriminalization would be for lack of a
better word the psychedelic spa where
you would check in and get that
buttressing because in all drug
experiences but particularly in
psychedelics the set and setting or as
you say are critical set is what you
bring to this experience and setting is
the setting in which you experience it
so like you know the Canyon Ranch of
psychedelics with with you know licensed
trained support team I'm not sure you
have to be a therapist per se but
someone with experience and training in
supporting an individual ideally with
preparation both before and after which
is not to say that I think all people
require that but that is that is much
more likely to engender a positive
response an interesting number is
Netherlands it is legal you can access
psilocybin magic mushrooms in the
Netherlands legally in coffee shops and
the Netherlands have the same mental
health crisis than every other country
in the world so just the fact that
psychedelics are available yeah
unfortunately to not change the mental
health price it is really like the
professional
if I experienced it with people like I
would look at my parents or our friends
with depression they're not making that
leap they'd rather go to their doctor
because they trust them and then the
doctor should be the one who is also
administering that so I'd like to touch
on something you said actually but that
we've sort of covered in a few different
ways but offer a framing that I think is
helpful and that is that rather than
think of good or bad trip think of safe
or unsafe trip because the in in many
cases the the difficult experiences are
when you see the truths you'd prefer not
to see and you look at the behaviors
that may be in your blind spot and that
can be very uncomfortable as in the case
when a smoker's like wow that's
disgusting I saw that I'm killing myself
and they have to look at that hard truth
difficult but safe and that depends a
lot on the context and the providers and
and so on a question for you Christian
how do you think about creating business
models around compounds that can be so
effective with a single dose or two
doses because I I know you want this to
be available to a great number of people
that requires a sustainable model of
some type and there many different ways
to approach it
you know Maps has one with say a B Corp
that does drug development then there
are for-profit options how do you look
out for temptations like taking
something it is so effective with one or
two doses and create creating something
that requires a maintenance dose
multiple times a week is it the
therapeutic wrapper that kind of spa
elements and context around which you
build a business how do you think about
that well first and meaning that sounds
may be cheesy or I was saying English
but like if you're investing in biotech
you really want to make a difference
because I do I would take investments
and I'm always very happy about biotech
because if you succeed in bringing a
drug to market you really make a
difference in the world so so I think
it's not I think this is a little bit
the most that everybody thinks biotech
investors are like evilly plotting
how to make the most out of it at least
this is not how I think about it that we
want to cure people and hopefully we're
gonna make that happen
second the market is so huge meaning I
said we have 320 million people and most
and the number is rising and I think
there are more people who are not
diagnosed so so even if and I would be
very very happy if it's a single dose to
the syphon which is which is helping
those people even if that's the case the
market is is huge yeah then you have the
decide business models or the violets at
the spas and the clinic's you can build
up yeah because it is all about the
holistic thing and and even and we don't
know yet many go for a lot of things we
also have to say like we have very good
indications but we don't know yet what
is the right dose this is for example
what compass is trying to figure out at
the moment it might be yeah I'm not
saying that because it should be like a
commercially but it might be that you
say oh if somebody was depressed you
should do it every year again we don't
know yet we try to figure that out yeah
but there is enough business and I think
in general like even if you go aside and
look at meditation at like calm for
example like I think that the whole
mental well-being like treating people
who are ill have mental health health
issues but also keeping people healthy
yeah in our current environment and and
this will get worse my personal theory
is that that our brain has like an
inbuilt
actually resilience so like an immune
system which is based on faith love and
purpose and if you look what our world
is happening we take these three things
away communities are dissolving families
are dissolving so you have cheese Edie
said a little bit less love in the world
yeah yeah then most people know that the
world will look so different in 20 years
that that they don't have a purpose
anymore the bus driver knows that in 20
years most likely his boss will be
driven by an artificial intelligence
yeah and and then we have a dramatic
loss of faith in every sense like
and in in any spiritual dimension and it
all will make people more oppressive so
Sonique we said the market is growing so
I'm not worried about about how often
you have to take it ok thanks
market is growing for better for worse
Madeleine I'd like to come to you first
all this I'll make another personal note
and try not to directly implicate myself
here but so my family has a on both
sides quite a bit of severe depression
and I'd say every six months or so as an
adult I've had a major depressive
episode almost killed myself when I was
an undergrad at Princeton I've written
about that you guys want to check it out
in the last five years I haven't had a
single major depressive episode and here
we are on this panel all the ego story
conclusions not to say that that is
going to be true 100 percent of the time
but given the fact that in one could
argue that there have been incredible
advances scientifically in cardiology
and neurology all these various fields
and then you look at psychiatry and
there's been very little I mean aside
from SSRIs some time ago and now
ketamine which is very interesting I
think for acute suicidal ideation and
chronic pain especially but there's very
little that has happened and so I'm very
very invested in this space mat the
reason I wanted to come to you next that
you mentioned scheduled one in scheduled
for one question that people might have
on their minds is well wait a second if
these are so great if they have such low
toxicity how did they end up in a
category schedule one which is no known
medical application high potential for
abuse among other things which of course
based on the data I disagree with but
like how did that happen and how do we
get out of that and I'll just say one
more thing because we're running short
on time which is you know my
not-so-secret agenda is to set the
conditions over the next three to five
years with private philanthropy and so
on so that I can then work separately to
try along with other people to help get
federal funding for this stuff which is
not currently forthcoming so how did we
get to this very difficult and expensive
position of operating from schedule
and how do we potentially get out yeah
this the quick answer is that psych that
it was really because of the association
with the counterculture and everything
associated with it in the late 60s early
70s and I would say that that the
culture was essentially traumatized from
that kind of early introduction of
psychedelics and and and there were
casualties when they were used broadly
there were also plenty of people said it
changed their lives for the better and
they're still here to talk about that
but this this came about right at the
time when the federal framework for
controlling scheduled drugs the
Controlled Substances Act was being
developed and there is no there are some
flaws in that system there is no
category for example of having no
accepted medical use but mild to
moderate abuse potential you know you
jump from having no accepted medical use
and high potential for abuse in schedule
one to schedule to something like
cocaine or methamphetamine which are
scheduled to as as having high high
potential for abuse but some accepted
medical value and those two drugs are
used medically and are approved so
there's really no framework now you know
psilocybin the language is important
here it we squarely know at every level
of science the defects and the Meza
limbic brain structures involving
dopamine the epidemiology reliable
animal models of reward we know that
these aren't drugs of addiction silently
but they are they can be drugs of abuse
and that simply means use in a way that
can can harm you or the people around
you so you know a couple teenagers
teenagers go out driving on mushrooms
that's abuse or you get into a pattern
or interferes with your family
relationships etc so they really don't
belong in
again the Controlled Substances Act is
is rather ambiguous in they refer to
abuse potential which can include
addiction potential but also other risks
so they do have risks you could argue
they have you know these classic
psychedelics mild abuse potential but
the other side of that is there's
there's no accepted medical value when
the Controlled Substances Act was
originally adopted it wasn't clear what
that really meant and through judicial
precedent it became solidified that what
that means is FDA approval for an
indication so that's where we're at now
so until one of these draw until
psilocybin is approved for an indication
it's going to by definition remain in
schedule one what are the most promising
indications currently or those that are
furthest along based on the data the
most promising indication would be
depression and anxiety you could call it
psychiatric distress associated with a
life-threatening cancer diagnosis that's
what the most modern most advanced
research with psilocybin as a
therapeutic has been focused on there's
three randomized studies in that
category and then secondary to that sort
of as a class are psilocybin in the
treatment of smoking cessation as a
smoking cessation medication I showed
you some data treatment of alcoholism a
colleague Mike bogan shoots at NYU has
done some great work with that and and
then Robins published work on depression
outside of cancer so all of those those
three things have been those are
published results with open label non
randomized pilot studies so they all
look very promising but they haven't
gone the published data hasn't reached
that level of you know large randomized
trials yet all of these disorders are
associated with being stuck in a narrow
mental and behavioral repertoire and as
Robin suggested I think that's why we're
seeing efficacy with these nominally
different disorders psychedelics have a
way to blast one out of that narrowed
mental
patois thank you uh uh uh where would
you hope would you hope this this field
that is broadly speaking psychedelics to
look like a few years from now give
anywhere you'd like to see it wait you
know um because I I went I was a lawyer
and I I was a criminal law professor and
so I think through this criminal justice
lens and I remember a period where
decriminalization of marijuana seemed
incomprehensible when we first started
working and I was working with the drug
policy Alliance on state initiatives to
decriminalize marijuana it seemed
remotely possible that in some very
liberal states you might have a medical
model and absolutely impossible that you
would ever have a recreational model and
I don't know about you guys but I've
been to these pot clubs which are like
Apple stores and the bud tenders are you
know showing you weed that in my
lifetime as a teenager in New Jersey I
never saw anything approaching so there
is a kind of there there the shift is
possible I think we could see a
medicalised model specifically for
psilocybin the reason that this research
is happening in psilocybin and not LSD
is because of the sort of fear
associated with LSD but they operate
wouldn't you say Matt almost identically
in the brain so I think we will see over
the course of the next decade and maybe
even less a shift to a medical approach
maybe maybe changing the schedule or
maybe on a statewide basis having this
as we did with marijuana marijuana still
Schedule one federally it's still a
crime federally but we have different
models state by state and I think that
we are a long way from a
decriminalization model for other for
drugs generally but I do think
psychedelics because of the research
that these gentlemen are doing does have
great potential for medical
applicability and I actually think what
can drive that more effectively than
anything else are the individuals in
this room and others like this which is
why I'm speaking to you and I imagine
that's why
here as well maybe the rest of the panel
because what we need is a model of
investment and corporate pressure to
change laws I mean that's the way it
works in America when there is a wave of
of capitalist interest it's a lot easier
for laws to change we are up on time of
closing comments real quickly check out
the research this is these are not
panaceas but they are the most exciting
thing that I've been focused on for the
last several years it's worth looking at
you have a chance if you're interested
in being on the playing field at having
a catherine mccormack level of impact
it's a big deal so please take a look
check out everybody on the panel and I
am Ella and I will be doing book signing
over there they're a couple chapters and
tools of titans on the psychedelic stuff
as well and thank you all for coming and
ladies ladies and gentlemen hey guys
this is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday and that provides a little morsel
of fun for the weekend
and 500 Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read
and that I've shared with my close
friends for instance and it's very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend
so if you want to receive that check it
out just go to four hour work week comm
that's four hour work week comm all
spelled out and just drop in if your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoyed
[Applause]
you